cette maison est désormais considérée
comme une scène de crime les policiers y
ont posé des scellés pour meurtre cette
nuit aux alentours d'une heure du matin
la mère de famille qui vit seule avec
son fils appelle les secours
elle déclare être tombé sur deux
cambrioleurs et avoir découvert son
enfant étouffé par un sac plastique
très vite les pompiers le samu arrivent
sur place mais ils ne parviendront pas à
réanimer le jeune garçon âgé de 8 ans
j'ai été appelé à 3h30 par la police
nationale et qui ensuite a été très vite
dessaisi du dossier au profit de la
police judiciaire de dijon
toute la matinée les enquêteurs et les
techniciens en investigation criminelle
procéderont à de multiples relevés
ils repartiront avec plusieurs scellés
la mer et des membres de la famille ont
été auditionnés au commissariat de
chalon sur saône
pendant ce temps l'histoire se répand
dans le quartier peu de voisins
s'exprime tout le monde est choqué c'est
un quartier calme s'envole un mauvais 1
par mois un bon présage pas tout je vois
pas disons que seriez ces dames est
rarement joué mon petit fils donc on
assez marqué la police étudie deux
hypothèses un cambriolage qui aurait mal
tourné mais surtout un infanticide à
saremi une cellule psychologique a été
mise en place pour les écoliers et les
membres du centre de loisirs que
fréquentait l'enfant